ladies and gentlemen here is a 1970
Academy Award nominee for Best Actress
Ali MacGraw
well we have one more best picture clip
to show you before pressing on that
picture is working girl
the saga of one woman's broken healed
climb up the ladder of corporate success
in this scene Melanie Griffith the
working girl in question meets Harrison
Ford quite by chance in the middle of
the wallstreet jungle and one of its
nicer watering holes
and now I would like to introduce a man
who is to die for at least that's what I
did the only time when I worked with him
we met we fell in love and I died in his
arms 92 minutes later tonight he's with
another woman
very beautiful talented actress but
that's okay with me because their love
stories for real
please welcome Farah Fawcett and Ryan
O'Neal
it is our pleasure tonight to present
the Oscar for achievement and film
editing a film editor puts all the shots
together and gives the movie its rhythm
if you need it to go faster or be
funnier or scary or bloodier or just
plain shorter the film editor is the guy
you call on I should know most of my
best work has been left on the cutting
room floor the nominees for the best
achievement in film editing are the
following gentlemen Frank J URI Asti and
John F link for die hard
Stewart there gorillas in the mist jaren
handling
Mississippi Burning
still endure for Rainman an Arthur
Schmidt for Who Framed Roger Rabbit and
the Oscar goes to
Arthur Schmidt for Who Framed Roger
Rabbit
well this is really incredible
I'd like to thank a terrific team of
incredibly talented collaborators who
made an enormous contribution to this
I'd especially like to thank Bob
Zemeckis for his brilliant direction it
was his vision his patience and his huge
talent that made Roger happen and he
made this happen thank you very much
thank you Bob